the crafting system in divinity original
sin - runs on a lot of trial and error
and many players under users useful tool
so I've compiled a short list of some of
the more interesting eclectic or useful
recipes for you to use
[Music]
if you're a little holder like me you'll
likely have a whole bunch of spell
scrolls you've not used scrolls are
great to use in a pinch but they're one
use only if you want to memorize the
spell itself then you can combine it
with a book from the same school of
abilities to create a skill book and
unlock the full spell
[Music]
you can actually create hybrid spells by
combining skill books from different
sets a total of 48 skills can be created
by crafting an elemental book with a non
elemental book blood storm for example
is made by combining necromancer and a
hydra fist book and sabotage an ability
that makes enemies grenades explode in
their pockets is crafted from a
scoundrel and a pyrokinetic book so make
sure you experiment with your spare
tomes for some awesome new abilities
there is an item that will let you be
reborn without the use of a resurrection
scroll if you talk to the rupture in the
under tavern during act 2 and start the
quest of web of desire you have the
opportunity to receive the item the
ashen Idol of rebirth now if you miss it
then you can always pickpocket
but either way this is a great item to
have if you combine it with a
resurrection scroll it will start
glowing and as long as you have it in
your inventory it will automatically
resurrect you as soon as you die now I
went over this item in my last tips
video but is a recipe everyone should
know icy surfaces can make your party
member slip costing you a valuable turn
in combat but if you combine nails with
any Footwear
they will permantly give you immunity to
slipping on your ass which is great for
fighting crime answers
[Music]
if you come across a news barrel while
exploring be sure to keep hold of it if
you combine any weapon with a barrel of
poison you will permantly gain poison
effects the boosts aren't major but
there are nice little extra to help you
chip away at enemy health if you've
explored radhika's cave and axe one
you'll know of the existence of the
blood rose now there is only one of
these in the game so I highly recommend
getting this item before you progress if
you combine the blood rose at an empty
potion bottle you will create the Attar
of the blood rose this item is awesome
as it gives you a plus one attribute
bonus to all attributes until you die so
as long as you keep the party member who
drank it alive that's a hefty permanent
stat increase
[Music]
charm arrows are some of the most useful
arrows in the game having an enemy
turning their pals can really turn the
tide of a fight so it's a good idea to
keep your wayfarer topped up now you can
craft these pretty easily by using honey
combine an arrowhead with a honey sauce
even better if you use beehive since
they have infinite nectar and you'll
create charmed arrowheads
now you can watching Glee as your
enemies take chunks out of each other
just because you made some arrows sticky
if you're having trouble keeping a hold
of lockpicks you can make your own
combined nails in a repair hammer or a
bar of soap and a key and you'll be able
to restock your lock picks useful for if
you really want to get into that chest
and you just happen to have some spare
soap lying around
[Music]
okay this one sounds obvious but I
didn't think of it straight away after a
few levels you might have a surplus of
minor healing potions well you can
combine the ones you're not using for
increased potency turning any tiny minor
potions all the way into life-giving
huge ones
and speaking of potions here's a neat
trick you can do to fool your co-op
partner if you have some red dye you can
pour it into a poison flask now remember
which one is which because it will turn
into a healing potion now the next time
your co-op Potter is in need of a HP
top-up generously offer them this potion
and laughs with Eve ugly as the poison
curses through them and they have no
idea why so those are a few of the
recipes we've been having some fun with
if you have any you'd like to recommend
then leave them in the comment section
for more divinity tips make sure you
check out our last three tips videos and
for everything else original sin you can
head over to GameSpot calm